a blanket of snow covers outfits but
does nothing to hide the horrors of this
former Nazi death camp
seventy years after it was liberated by
the Red Army around 300 former prisoners
gather in front of the camp's gate of
death they sit either side of the tracks
which carried many of them in cattle
trucks into this extermination factory
more than a million people were murdered
here
most of them Jews Halina bierenbaum
was just a child but remembers the hell
with tragic clarity all around us
electric barbed wire and rows of
barracks stinking mud and some figures
muddling through
I cannot tell whether they are old or
young women or men a disgusting mass of
people all in lousy wet rags with
numbers shaven heads those gray faces
with legs like sticks wearing those
muddy clogs nothing reminding you of
anything remotely human outfits was a
place of sophisticated torture of
efficient killing humanity stripped from
every inch of this huge site all these
years on the same message echoes around
the miserable walls we survivors do not
want how it best to be our children's
future a warning repeated for global
leaders gathered at the event there are
representatives today from 40 countries
you are good decent people and but
because of what we are and what this
place means your governments must stand
up to this new wave of hatred in London
a similar ceremony the government's
announced it's giving 50 million pounds
towards a new memorial and the Prince of
Wales added his thoughts about the
importance of remembering it enables us
to rally together to recognize the
workings of wickedness to exercise
vigilance and hopefully to stop such
atrocities in the future
the biting cold can't freeze the fiery
determination of these survivors the
worn seven decades on prejudice must
never become policy hatred must never be
tolerated
Jonathan Samuels Sky News